well over the weekend I was looking at
my mutual fund account to see how things
went in May and it is very very ugly one
of the worst months other than October
of 2018 and December of 2018
one of the worst months ever for my
mutual fund account and part of it was
this precipitous market decline that
happened at the end of May because of
Donald Trump escalating the world trade
war again this time by announcing new
tariffs on Mexico which are quite
frankly absolutely ridiculous and I'm
gonna explain to you exactly why today
the markets are realizing effectively
that Donald Trump really is this dumb
Donald Trump really is this ignorant
about basic economics and trade and it
is really getting ugly out there in the
economic sense Donald Trump as you might
know and we've talked about started a
trade war with China and we've gotten
nothing substantive out of it and it has
been a disaster for American companies
and American taxpayers American
companies and taxpayers not China have
paid billions in extra dollars as a
result of Donald Trump's tariffs on
China five trillion dollars has
disappeared in value from the stock
market there is no credible off-ramp
from these tariffs anytime soon meaning
a way for Trump to get us out of them
and to sort of deescalate and go back to
where we were before and in the meantime
China continues to simply make other
arrangements China's making deals with
Russia on energy China's doing more
trade with other countries and what does
Donald Trump decide to do he decides to
start another trade war this time with
Mexico Trump announcing obviously on
Twitter where else is he going to do it
that there will be a five percent tariff
on Mexican goods until illegal
immigrants stopped coming to the US and
that five percent could escalate
significantly Donald Trump tweeting
quote on June 10th the United States
will impose a five percent tariff on all
goods coming into our country from
Mexico until such time as illegal
migrants coming through Mexico
and into our country stop the tariff
will gradually increase until the
illegal immigration problem is remedied
at which time the tariffs will be
removed details from the White House to
follow what Donald Trump is saying is
that Americans will be paying 5% more
for Mexican Goods and Trump later
followed this up by saying that the five
percent becomes 10 percent quote if the
crisis persists and then there would be
an additional five percentage points
each month for three months getting all
the way up to potentially according to
the president a twenty five percent
tariff on Mexican goods coming to the
United States this is true real idiocy
you know sometimes I look a search hard
for the right words to use to describe
economic policy or socio-cultural policy
or political decisions this is just
idiocy and it's actually getting so
stupid that that even many Republicans
are saying this is a bad idea the
horribly depraved disgusting Republican
ideologue Chuck Grassley even has the
sense to say that these Mexico tariffs
are a misuse of presidential authority
but there's something truly mind-blowing
and and just dumb about this the point
here is that Donald Trump wants to hurt
Mexico with this policy right Donald
Trump doesn't like what he sees as
Mexican I guess indifference when it
comes to undocumented immigration from
Mexico to the United States so he wants
to hurt Mexico now let's put aside for a
second that there's a net outflow of
immigration to Mexico even accounting
for undocumented that most of the people
that are coming in over the border many
of the people are actually coming from
countries further south than Mexico so
really we should be dealing with the
economic situations in those countries
if you actually want to reduce the
demand of those citizens to go through
Mexico and try to get into the United
States put all of that stuff aside Trump
wants to hurt Mexico with this policy if
Trump succeeds in hurting Mexico with
these new tariffs that will make the
Mexican economic situation worse
which will create
a demand for more Mexicans to try to
come to the United States legally and
illegally which is what Donald Trump is
trying to stop these tariffs are
completely counterproductive we've gone
from Mexico is definitely going to pay
for the wall to Mexico is not paying for
the wall and now there isn't even a wall
to we are going to put tariffs on
avocados and cars and all of the stuff
that comes from Mexico we're gonna make
that more expensive for Americans while
potentially increasing the motivation
that Mexicans will have to come to the
United States illegally I thought we
were told that businessman president
genius Trump was gonna bring us economic
prosperity we were told that this is
some kind of complex 4d chess that
Donald Trump is executing on trade which
many of his followers during the
campaign who by the way know nothing
about trade people who know nothing
about trade fell hook line and sinker
for the idea that Donald Trump knew how
to fix it
it's not happening this is triggering
the possibility of a recession and that
probability keeps growing a second trump
term could be utterly devastating to the
economy of this type of completely
uninformed tariff policy continues and
the most important and stunning thing
about this is that both Donald Trump and
his followers and some people who aren't
his followers to be quite fair and full
don't understand that when you tariffs
China or Mexico they don't pay for it
the importing companies and people in
the United States are the ones that pay
for it now I I don't want to ignore the
sort of economic theory behind the
tariff the idea is that even though
strictly speaking the tariff is paid by
the importing countries companies and
individuals if we bring avocados from
Mexico to the US and they have a 5%
tariff it's the u.s. importer that pays
the 5% which they pass along to the
consumer so avocados end up costing 5%
more the economic theory
kind it is if you let's imagine that
American avocados are 3% more expensive
than Mexican avocados if you put a five
percent tariff on the Mexican avocado
the idea would be you will boost local
business because you now have the option
of either Mexican avocados with a 5
percent tariff on top or American
avocados which are only 3 percent more
expensive these are imaginary numbers so
you would shift consumption from the
Mexican avocado to the American avocado
the problem is that we are starting to
tariff items that are not the the you
can't easily shift production in the way
that would be required for it to work in
that way when we're talking about
aluminum and steel from China which are
building materials that are you don't
just switch your supplier overnight
companies don't have that flexibility
they're not nimble in that way when
there is a certain demand for avocados
that's based on the fact that we are
getting them from Mexico you can't just
put a five percent tariff on avocados
and all of a sudden it's all American
avocados that everybody's buying the
supply is not there it takes a while to
grow these things cars it takes a while
if you're buying cars that are built in
Mexico and a tariff gets placed on them
you can't immediately shift production
in order to account for that in a way
that will work the way Trump maybe
believes it would work so we're gonna
dig into that more after the break but
once again markets are realizing Trump
doesn't know what the hell is going on
with these tariffs let me know what you
think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
the list of people who believe that
Donald Trump is not going to relinquish
control of the White House peacefully if
he loses the 2020 election is growing
and it includes at least one Republican
candidate now who happens to be running
against Donald Trump his name's William
weld he is a former governor here in
Massachusetts he previously was running
as a libertarian he now is a Republican
and he says that Donald Trump will not
leave voluntarily if he loses the 2020
election from Real Time with Bill Maher
Bill Maher asked if Trump blew
do you think he'll leave and William
weld said not voluntarily he'll have a
run at saying it was a rigged game so
I'm not leaving I don't think the
military and indeed even the Justice
Department the rank-and-file the
investigative agencies would stand for
that in this country
I like that William weld added that last
piece because it's important for us on
the left and not that William weld is on
the left but for anyone on the left who
is even entertaining this idea of what
would Trump do would he try to hold on
to control if he lost the 2020 election
we are not like the crazy right with the
birther stuff and the Obama's going to
cancel the 2016 election stuff which is
why I think it's important to point out
that William weld is not saying Trump
would succeed at staying in the White
House even if he lost the 2020 election
he might try to pull it or try to delay
it but ultimately the centers of power
in the country wouldn't allow it and I
also think that that's the most likely
scenario and every single time that this
comes up I go out of my way not to be
hyperbolic because with Obama there was
so much nonsense about Obama won't leave
Obama will cancel the 2016 election and
declare himself indefinite president or
Obama will declare martial law as a
justification for remaining president
beyond his eight years we want to be a
sober and realistic as possible about
this with Barack Obama
there was no indication whatsoever that
Barack Obama had those sort of
anti-democratic authoritarian tendencies
with regard to the presidency in trying
to not relinquish power
there was nothing Obama said which
suggested that he might out of his own
concoction
not accept the results of an election so
when the right said Obama won't leave it
was 110 percent BS with Trump it's not a
hundred and ten percent BS it's still
not likely that it would happen though
right Trump has all the way back to 2016
in the debates said maybe he would
accept the election results maybe he
wouldn't if they showed that he lost
depending on what he thinks about the
election results Trump has said
president for life like what China made
possible recently is interesting and
maybe we would try it sometime
Trump has said years ahead of the 2020
election two years ahead that the only
way Democrats can defeat him in 2020 is
via fraud that is yet another one of
these sort of pretexts to the idea that
he might not accept the election results
Trump has lied about the validity of
past elections remember he claimed three
to five million people voted illegally
in 2016 for Hillary Clinton and that in
reality if you account for those three
to five million alleged illegal votes he
won the popular vote as well as the
electoral vote Trump has made clear that
he has a degree of narcissism that might
make him unable emotionally to accept
defeat so when people talk about Trump
won't leave the White House peacefully
if he loses is it more likely that he
would try to retain power than would
someone like Barack Obama obviously the
answer is yes is it likely Trump would
succeed if he tried at not relinquishing
the White House I don't think it's very
likely so what what we need to do is
let's just work on voting him out rather
than focusing on whether or not he would
leave let's work on preventing voter
suppression and manipulation tactics to
actually hand Donald Trump the victory
because much more likely than Trump
loses and somehow stays in the White
House is that the combination of voter
ID laws and election machine tampering
and foreign influence and reductions in
voting hours and closures of polling
places all together push Donald Trump
into victory that's what we need to most
proactively be working to prevent I
agree with William weld that if Trump
tries not to give up control of the
White House that the forces of power I
know that the Justice Department's in
the tank forum I know all of that stuff
but I think that that would even be too
far I think that he would ultimately be
removed and there's a really big problem
in American culture today American
political culture today that this
relates to expectations expectations
aren't being managed properly so take
impeachment for example which will talk
about the expectation shouldn't be can
we remove Trump via impeachment by the
2020
election because that's not happening
the expectation should
can impeachment proceedings expose the
content of the Moller report enough to
damage Trump to make sure that he loses
the 20/20 election we have to manage our
expectations and similarly if Trump
loses the 20/20 election and tries to
stay in power could he actually do it
I believe William weld is right and the
answer is no that he would be removed
but he might try to argue that the
election was bogus that it was rigged
that it was fraudulent whatever because
he's done it before in an election he
won but who knows what he would do in an
election that he loses last thing on
this the idea that the reason Trump
would be so adamant about not losing has
been floated as maybe being the statute
of limitations on obstruction there's
this idea that Trump it's not so much
that he wants to be president for
another four years although his ego
would take a hit if he were to lose but
it's the idea that if he is not
president for another four years he
could end up indicted for obstruction
because the statute of limitations would
not have expired there is a way around
that which would be if Trump loses the
2020 election three days before the
inauguration of the next president Trump
resigns Mike Pence becomes president and
issues a pre-emptive pardon for Donald
Trump it might work it might not the
legal experts have sort of different
views on that but there is a path even
if Trump loses in 2020 to protecting
himself from indictment on obstruction
after he's gone just something to keep
in mind so remember the stunt Donald
Trump pulled Sunday showing up at a
church and the White House said that he
showed up to pray for the victims of the
shooting the mass shooting that took
place in Virginia last week or on Friday
last Friday President Trump showed up to
a church and it was apparently not as
the pastor is now reporting they did not
show up to pray for the victims of the
mass shooting but instead to pray for
the president himself you have to be
some kind of scumbag to lie about the
reason that you're praying especially
when you're supposed to be praying for
the victims I mean the all Republicans
do in a
mass shooting or after a mass shooting
is to all four thoughts and prayers but
apparently the President of the United
States isn't even offering prayers
genuinely here's a quote from the
article in The Huffington Post says
quote a pastors explanation of President
Donald Trump Trump's sudden visit to his
church on franklin graham's pray for
Donald Trump's day is casting doubt on
the White House it's widely publicized
claim that he went there to pray for
Friday's shooting victims in Virginia
Beach David Platt pastor of McLean Bible
Church a few miles from Trump's Golf
Course in Northern Virginia wrote in a
statement that he first heard about
Trump's visit after he finished his
sermon early Sunday afternoon so much to
unpack there that's actually worthwhile
first of all why in the hell are we
having a national pray for Trump day
that I can write an entire book about
why not only is that problematic but
it's also it's also just a tool to rally
evangelical voters to the Republican
Party and and it's been this this
symbiotic relationship between the
evangelical church and republicanism
since Ronald Reagan actually did write a
book about it now think about it God is
not a Republican but that that part
setting that part aside the fact that
the president was still in his golf
outfit his golf clothes and and he
wished then really quick to get a
photo-op praying for the victims of the
mass shooting but it ended up just
turning out to be a prayer for him I
mean there's layers and layers of
hypocrisy it's already in the story but
I want to read one more paragraph from
Huffington Post it said quote the white
house though had given a different
reason for the visit just as Trump was
walking into the church the press office
sent out a statement claiming that he
was there to visit the pastor and pray
for the victims and community of
Virginia Beach yet during the entirety
of Trump's 16-minute stay Platt the
pastor did not mention the shooting and
Trump never spoke about the shooting or
anything else beyond thanking Platt
afterwards so I mean I guess you could
chalk this up and say it was just oh
it's just a miscommunication they didn't
really come
the reason that they were there I mean
if you want to be generous sure you can
talk that up and but but why does it
matter
it matters because it's consistent it's
a very consistent theme with Donald
Trump and Republicans and conservatives
in general all for different reasons
it's a it's a it's a consistent theme
with Donald Trump to be a habitual liar
right he lies about everything but
particularly he lies about his religion
and his faith and he presents himself or
you know let me take that back
evangelicals tried to present Donald
Trump as some type of reverent pious
person who is ordained by God to fix
America when a reality Trump is just
aligned
well we're on David show so I can't use
profanity but Trump is an outright liar
about his belief system about politics
about his ego I mean it there's no facet
of Donald Trump's life that he is not
compelled to lie about and and so this
is just a really consistent theme with
Donald Trump he's also opportunistic I
mean he literally still had on his golf
shoes you know coming in whisking in the
church there was a paragraph that I
wanted to read but the church is
actually the closest church to the golf
course so he didn't really say okay I'm
going to go to Virginia so that I can
pray for these people what actually
happened was he realized or an assistant
realized that Donald Trump is in
Virginia and in Virginia Beach and he's
not there on behalf of the victims he's
there to play golf how do we fix it well
you have some enterprising assistant who
says okay what we can do is let's shoot
over to the local church and say a
prayer for the victims but they didn't
relay that information to the pastor see
how that works so not only does Donald
Trump a liar he's opportunistic and and
really quite frankly did not care about
those victims enough to realize that he
was in Virginia and hadn't really done
anything but except go golfing and then
somebody tried to fix a problem
ultimately making the problem he
worse the stories also significant
because of what I was discussing with
Franklin Graham with the evangelical
movement absolutely trying to spin
Donald Trump to be something more than
this this this I really only have a
religious word this is lascivious this
this disgusting man who was driven by
nothing but his ego and his passions who
is the exact opposite of everything
evangelicals preach Donald Trump is the
exact opposite of everything that
evangelicals preach but because he is
their political tool Donald Trump is
their political pawn they're willing to
give him a mulligan
to use some golf tournament erm analogy
they're willing to give him a mulligan
to forget about all of the different
ways Donald Trump demonstrates that he
is absolutely the opposite of anything
Jesus would have been or do but
evangelicals don't care about that they
care about their political agenda most
of their political agenda is about
taking away a woman's right to choose
attacking the LGBTQ community of
marriage equality they don't care about
anything else but those things they
don't care about any other form of
morality they don't care about economic
justice they don't care about oppression
and what capitalism does to poor people
they don't care about children after
they're born they don't care about any
of that Donald Trump is great to them
because Donald Trump gives them an
opportunity to do everything they want
on particularly on taking away a woman's
right to choose so as far as
evangelicals are concerned Donald Trump
probably could shoot somebody on Fifth
Avenue and still be one of their
favorite presidents and the last thing
and not to not to belabor the point too
much but this idea of praying for the
president when in fact the last
administration they prayed against the
president shows the hypocrisy that
they're not operating in terms of any
sense of real any real sense of faith
and being concerned about the leadership
of our country they're only concerned
about the leadership of this country
that serves their political interest
welcome back to the david patten show
benjamin dickson filling in for David
while he is appearing on the Joe Rogan
podcast if you're just seeing this video
soon enough David will be live at 3 p.m.
on
Romans channel YouTube channel and if
you're watching this video at a later
point then obviously go and watch the
replay I'm sure it's gonna be a
fascinating conversation file this next
video
this next story under being so committed
to your racism that it backfires a 70
year old Ruby how has been arrested she
was first fired and that she was
arrested as a result of a video that
went viral that showed her pulling a gun
on two black people as they attended or
tried to find a place to have a picnic
Ruby nelle how is a 70 year old white
woman and the video really speaks
volumes about so many things that still
have to be discussed today take a look
at the video
this lady literally just poured a gun
because we out here do have reservations
like that we didn't even know we had to
have reservation for we don't know no I
don't know you had to tell us we didn't
know don't think why do you tell us to
leave we would have live you did not
have to pull a gun
with this this all you have to say
that's all you have to say well that's
fine that's fine now I mean it's it's
really impossible to look at that video
and not discuss it in the broader
context of so many things that are still
happening in this country but very
specifically the history of this country
the the historical baggage the racial
baggage that still exists in this
country I mean it's I have to discuss it
in that context because look at how
shockingly quick this escalated to a
life-threatening situation for this
black couple who basically just went out
to look for a place to barbecue she
pulled a gun because they weren't
supposed to be there well Ruby nelle how
works for that campsite and she no
longer works there but she did and I'm
quite sure that's not the first time
someone came to looking to use their
facilities without an appointment I mean
quite frankly most people when you're
looking for a place to barbecue you look
for a public space and you just go there
and then you find out you know by ok
it's it's just it's it's free to use
that I don't need an appointment or you
need a permit and you need an
appointment but in none of the
situations that I have ever encountered
that it remotely similar to this and I'm
sure for you as well a matter of fact I
would guarantee 99% of everyone
listening probably 100% of everyone
listening if you encounter a situation
where you showed up somewhere where you
needed a permit or you needed to make an
appointment nobody pulled a gun out on
you to demonstrate that you didn't have
the right to be there but Ruby now how
of Starkville Mississippi thought that
that was the right thing to do so not
only did she lose her job but she also
was arrested on for threatening except
for a threatening exhibition of a weapon
she was she turned herself in and got
out on a whopping $500 bond now again I
I don't really want to belabor the point
too much but you have to put a fine
point on this fact in some state
she would have been better off if she
had killed that couple and as
inflammatory is that statement sounds
you have to understand states like
Florida and Georgia have Stand Your
Ground laws that allows a person to use
weapons to quote/unquote defend
themselves when they fear for their life
and they have the right to stand their
ground which which really I bring it up
because you have to ask yourself the
question at what point is the
unreasonable and irrational fear of
black people going to be addressed in
situations like this but more
specifically in situations where people
stand their ground because this woman
had literally no reason whatsoever to
fear this couple no reason whatsoever to
pull a gun on this couple but she pulled
it out but I mean for wat'ry I mean she
you have to say she was afraid right you
don't just pull unless you you're
pulling out the gun just to you know
just for a power-play well that
backfired for as well but there's an
irrational level of fear that that is
connected to black people and that's
intentional
I mean I can break this down so many
different ways and come to my channel
and I now do that but that's intentional
like this irrational fear that would
lead this woman to pull a gun on a
couple a married couple not that that
should be a qualifier and then oh if
they're not married or if they weren't a
couple they should have had it no no no
but still it's a you know a married
couple looking to have a barbecue and
this woman either just wanted to show
how bad she was or she had some
irrational fear going on and led to her
pulling the gun out thank goodness she
didn't use it but in so many cases we
see across the country those weapons are
use and people lose their lives because
of this irrational fear that has been
baked into this American society it's
the vilification of blackness goes all
the way back to the justification for
slavery because there had to have be
there had to have been a level of
dehumanization that took place for
people to justify and say Oh
particularly for Christians in this
country to say oh well slavery even
though you know it's okay because
they're not really human it trickles
down through generations it this fear
it's irrational fear I'm gonna get off
this one and just move on to something
funny but this irrational fear trickles
down through the generations and it is
still here today and we see incidents
like this that could really have led to
the death of people for no reason
whatsoever based on some irrational fear
that is baked into this American system
okay I have a clip for you today that is
notable not only for its absurdity and
its stupidity as much as it's notable
for its truly xenophobic basis when you
listen to what it is that Tucker Carlson
said on his show the other day in
dismissing the idea that Russia
interfered in the 2016 election even
though they did even though the Moller
report makes that clear even though our
intelligence agencies all found that
Russia interfered Tucker Carlson did
something sort of slick I'll admit it
sort of slick sort of ignorant and it's
very xenophobic but it is a little bit
slick he said that the real election
interference is Mexican people who
legally became citizens of the United
States and then voted as is their right
of citizenship it's as ridiculous as it
sounds I'm gonna play a clip for you
where Tucker Carlson is apparently
arguing that everything Russia did for
which we have endless evidence is not
interference in an election but that
Mexican people who come here legally
become citizens and then choose to vote
is a form of interference now you've got
to listen really carefully to the words
that are used and what Tucker Carlson
says here take a look well if you watch
Robert Muller speak this morning at
11:00 you heard him echo the view of
official Washington that Russia had a
major effect on the 2016 election well
as we've noted before that is an absurd
claim there's zero evidence that it's
true none that Robert Muller himself has
presented but if you're looking for
countries that really do influence
American politics there are quite a few
anyone who lives in DC can tell you that
Russia does not make the list Mexico
definitely does at the beginning of the
past presidential election cycle for
example Mexico
again what Bloomberg News described as
an unprecedented effort to get American
citizenship for its permanent residents
living here in the u.s. the point was
obvious of course to make them voters so
they could vote to defeat Donald Trump
Russia never even considered election
hacking that bold Tucker is suggesting
here that Mexicans who meet the
requirements to become citizens and
become citizens and then choose to vote
are committing a type of interference in
the election that is actually
interference unlike what Russia did in
2016
number one citizens voting is not
interference in an election it's called
the election process right when people
are citizens and they vote that is not a
way to interfere with the election it is
a way to participate in the election the
definition of interference is the action
of interfering or the process of being
interfered with when American citizens
vote it's not interfering with the
election process it's the election
process when Russia medals accesses
voting systems helps one candidate get
dirt on another runs social media
campaigns and trolling campaigns and
fake news campaigns and disinformation
campaigns online that is not a main
election process those are actions that
are interfering with the election when
you get beyond that you realize that
this is fundamentally xenophobic because
the underlying motivation or implication
here is that well yeah of course
citizens get to vote here but when it's
brown people from Mexico who obtained
citizenship through naturalization it's
not really part of the democratic
process it's an interference with the
democratic process now from a logistical
standpoint can you imagine this as a
strategy to effect election results by
Mexico you're counting on people from
Mexico coming to the United States
legally living here long enough to
qualify to apply for citizenship
applying for citizenship paying all of
the associated costs eventually getting
that citizenship all to vote in
elections legally as a means to effect
election
it would be an incredibly stupid and
inefficient way to try to affect the
election results in the United States
and if you believe that you would
probably believe the idea as many
trumpets do that Barack Obama was part
of a conspiracy that dates back to his
birth to get a foreigner to be President
of the United States some kind of
shadowy entity that I guess forty five
years before Barack Obama became
president faked the birth certificate to
make sure that a foreign-born dude would
be President in 2008 in the United
States they faked his parents they faked
the birth certificate who knows what the
latest version of that conspiracy is if
you believe that then I guess maybe you
would believe that Mexicans having the
long-term plan of becoming legal
citizens in order to vote is a way to
interfere and affect elections any
normal sensible rational person would
realize the absurdity of it and as part
of this kind of long game idea you don't
actually need to go to that Mexican
conspiracy to understand the long game
that Russia has been playing I mean go
back to the 1997 book foundations of
geopolitics by Alexander Dugan and you
will see that everything Russia has been
doing in the United States and elsewhere
for the last several years was written
out and suggested as a strategy for
sowing geopolitical chaos to Russia's
advantage more than 20 years ago in the
book foundations of geopolitics but
listen this is it if you're in Tucker
Carlson's core Fox News audience you
probably hear this idea of Mexicans are
interfering by legally becoming citizens
and voting it's probably a great fit for
you and it's probably the type of stuff
that makes Tucker Carlson have those
solid ratings on Fox News disgusting
absolutely disgusting but I understand
why Tucker Carlson saying it because his
audience is eating it up like it's being
spoon-fed to them welcome back to the
David Pakman show
benjamin dickson filling in for David
David is away in Los Angeles appearing
on the Joe Rogan podcast so I'm sure
that's gonna be a great conversation
glad to be here with you today go over
to the Benjamin diction show on YouTube
and subscribe new content is up and it's
my birthday so you know help me get over
25,000 subscribers but anyway let's get
to the news everything conservatives do
trying to attack al
Andrea Cassio Cortese instantly turns
into a commercial for her there's a
tweet by a guy Ryan Saavedra
he works for Ben Shapiro's daily wire
and he tweeted this out there's two
parts I'm gonna read the tweet first and
then I want you to watch the video the
video was a little difficult to hear but
it's worth watching this is what he said
on Twitter quote Socialist
Representative Alexandria Kazuya Cortez
of democratic New York on her 93
trillion
Green Deal green New Deal quote you have
the right to a job you have the right to
an education you have the right to
health care a right to a dignified home
and a right to a dignified retirement
let's take a listen into that clip so
here's the thing I find it hilarious
that every single thing Republicans
think is going to be a turn-off about
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes instantly
becomes a turn-on
in terms of politics in her political
stance I want to make sure that was
clear what I'm talking about there but
seriously do you think anyone looking at
this except a sadist would look at this
and say oh this is just something that
we absolutely don't want these are
things that we don't want know if anyone
has a problem with having a right to a
job a right to an education a right to
health care and a right to a dignified
home housing and a right to a dignified
retirement all of those things are
really a part of what the American dream
always was particularly for baby boomers
the baby boomer generation these things
were expected a job a decent job a
decent education so anyone who looks at
that and has a problem with it is really
quite sadistic number one but number two
the only question that should be asked
about this is how do we pay for it not
in this Republican way they're like oh
how are we
get this done but if there's any
question is how do we pay for it and
then you look at where we're doing all
of the spending we're currently doing
particularly on all of all of our wars
on the defense contractors all the money
that is wasted in our economy already
without even raising taxes on the
wealthy any more than it currently is
there's enough money that's being wasted
for us to take care of all of these
things notwithstanding the fact that we
absolutely should raise taxes on the
wealthiest people in this country not
just because Donald Trump just lowered
them but because they were already
historically low those are the ways that
we pay for these things that's how we
get these things done and and and and
the emphasis that he puts if you don't
mind putting the tweet back on the
screen from Ryan from The Daily wire he
said Socialist Representative Alexandria
Acacio Cortez
first of all breath you're not scaring
anyone away with the word socialist
anymore you guys kind of you know you
guys jump the shark with that with Obama
when every other sentence was a
socialist MAOIs Leninist communist Obama
turns out everybody did well all the
capitalists did well under Barack Obama
because Barack Obama was not a socialist
Barack Obama was a capitalist but
because you guys overplayed that card so
much nobody looks at this and says oh my
goodness she's a socialist and these are
terrifying things that's number one
nobody's afraid of a socialist anymore
thank you for that by the way but number
two nothing that she says here is
remotely socialism in the way that
they're trying to promote it as
socialism I am pretty sure I've had this
conversation with this audience before
but let me emphasize something Bernie
Sanders in Alexandria Acacio Cortes are
not socialists they are at best post
office socialists they are FDR style
capitalists they are trying to save
capitalism from itself if you want to
meet some real socialists let me
introduce you to some of my friends who
are like so far to the left of me
that they scare me right there's actual
communists
in the country who want to seize the
mean of production means of production
right away you know like like gulags and
guilt guilt things right away Bernie
Sanders and the green New Deal and
Alexandria Acacio Cortez this is nothing
more than post office socialism where we
take a few tax dollars and we put it
together so that we can do something for
the common welfare to promote the
general welfare goodness right if if you
like firefighters then you are a
socialist
according to Republicans right if you
like public schools then you're a
socialist according to Republicans
that's because they have a fetish they
feta sighs privatization of everything
that is their solution to everything not
because they think it's going to make it
better but because they know that they
can make a profit off of it and they
know they could take those taxes it's
not as though they want the government
to not collect the tax dollars that is
currently collecting not-not-not the
enterprising capitalists not not these
not the well I was gonna say new
capitalist but they've been doing this
for hundreds of years but what they want
as are those tax dollars to be paid to
private industry so private industry can
do the same thing the government would
do but charge a little bit more and make
a profit off of it that's what they want
right so they are socialists they just
want socialism going to the wealthy not
going to the poor and so what they do is
they use a scare tactic and say oh oh
because she believes Alexandria cosmic
Cortes believes that everyone has a
right to a job oh she wants to turn
America into Venezuela right Acacio
Cortes thinks everyone has a right to
health care Oh Venezuela
never mind the fact that what's going on
in Venezuela is not even the result of
socialism as much as it is a result of
Americans sanctions and a result of the
swings and oil prices because Venezuela
was overwhelmingly dependent on oil but
I digress they used that as a scare
tactic so that you can never ever demand
more from this country based on what
we're putting into this country and
based on what the wealthiest people in
this country should be putting in
they scared you with socialism Venezuela
warming a dignified retirement is
socialism and Venezuela and Acacio
Cortez is a socialist these are the
games that the Republicans have been
playing for years and and we're finally
at it finally at a tipping point where
people are not terrified by those terms
anymore no one is going to look at a
socialist and be like oh this is the
most terrifying thing that I've ever
seen and thank thanks in part to yes
Bernie Sanders being very consistent
over the last I don't know 30 40 50 60
70 years of his career
love you Bernie and and thanks in part
also to Republicans using that term over
and over and over again and now people
are like well you know what if the post
office is socialism to you then I'm okay
with post office socialism and we should
go one step further and we should have a
nationalized health care system right
with single-payer medicare medicare for
all go even further like we should have
a right to a job that it is it is very
we are we are the wealthiest country in
the history of the world it's no reason
why we cannot get every person in this
country a job and what last but not
least here's here's a the the the
disgusting part about it is that every
single one of these things of the right
to a job the right to an education right
to health care right to a dignified home
and right to a dignified retirement
every single one of those things based
on how America currently is if we gave
every American one of those things
private industry would benefit private
industry would get the spoils of all of
these benefits that we're giving to
individuals it will absolutely trickle
up to private industry but that's not
good enough for Republicans that's not
good enough for capitalists they don't
want to profit off of your well-being
they want to take the last dime and suck
every penny out of your life and out of
your soul they are vultures that's the
irony of this is that we actually could
all do well but they don't want that
they would rather they do well and well
you just uh good luck